ein milliardenmarkt sortiert sich neu
deutschland erlaubt das glücksspiel im
internet und versucht die suchtgefahr im
blick zu halten
immer mehr infizierte wie gefährlich ist
die neue lungenkrankheit aus china wir
haben antworten eines experten und
politisch lachte manz enthebung
verfahren für die oppositionellen
demokraten gibt es eine schlappe die
regeln diktieren trumps republik haben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber guten abend in allen
heute um 7 wir sind ihr überblick über
diese nachrichten mittwoch der
sportliche teil mit kristin rundum mit
tennis und handball kommt wir beginnen
mit sehr viel geld und zwar in jeder
hinsicht glücksspiel im internet ist bei
uns bald generell erlaubt geplant sind
aber auch regeln zum schutz der spieler
jahrelang hatten die bundesländer
miteinander gerungen jetzt sind sie sich
einig sie wollen damit den illegalen
markt eindämmen und natürlich steuern
einnehmen glücksspiel insgesamt ist ein
riesengeschäft in deutschland allein der
offizielle regulierte teil der branche
nahm 2018 mehr als elf milliarden euro
ein
lotterien spielbanken pferdewetten unter
anderem das ist der legale teil
daneben existiert aber der bisher nicht
regulierte markt rund 2,6 milliarden
euro erträge aus online casinos und
virtuellen poker spielen ohne lizenz und
damit illegal aber geduldet oliver
flammen zeigt was sich jetzt ändert und
welche gefahren beim zocken ohne grenzen
lauern mit fünf euro startet er seine
erste sportwette doch schnell kommt die
spielsucht werden die einsätze immer
höher
innerhalb von zwei jahren hat der junge
mann hunderttausend euro verzockt man
ist ständig am handy oder am computer
schläft nachts nicht weil schon die
nächste wette läuft auf irgendwelche
fußball spiele tennis oder volleyball
irgendwas einfach nur um das geld wieder
zu bekommen und keine verluste zu machen
es ist ein teufelskreis vor allem online
casino spiele gelten als problematisch
bisher sind sie in den meisten ländern
illegal und werden nur geduldet in
zukunft sollen sie erlaubt sein
wir haben über 50 milliarden auf dem
illegalen markt an spieleinsätzen dies
zu kontrollieren was da eigentlich
passiert das war das ziel und das wird
uns mit diesen neuregulierung
staatsvertrag gelingen um spieler vor
suchtgefahr zu schützen soll jeder
maximal 1000 euro pro monat für online
spiele einsetzen dürfen
außerdem werden bekannte risiko spieler
in einer sperrdatei erfasst oder können
sich selbst dort eintragen
und eine zentrale aufsichtsbehörde soll
überwachen dass anbieter die regeln auch
einhalten
kritiker fordern vor allem ein
werbeverbot für online glücksspiele und
das monatliche limit sei viel zu hoch
das durchschnittseinkommen liegt bei
1900 euro im monat unter gesetzgeber
signalisiert es ist okay
1000 euro im monat zu verspielen das ist
keine gute botschaft zocken jederzeit am
smartphone oder von zu hause ein
besonderes risiko
experten halten die suchtgefahr durch
online glücksspiel für wesentlich höher
als beim spielen in der spielhalle
unser nächstes thema mehr tote mehr
infizierte in china das corona virus
breitet sich weiter aus jetzt im moment
berät der notfall ausschuss der
weltgesundheitsorganisation über
mögliche internationale maßnahmen zur
vorsorge
die zahl der toten ist auf 17 gestiegen
mehr als 470 menschen haben sich in
asien angesteckt erstmals wurde das
virus auch in den usa nachgewiesen
der mann kam aus der chinesischen stadt
wo hahn dem mutmaßlichen ursprungsort
der krankheit wie gefährlich das virus
für uns ist hat uns ein experte erklärt
julia schröter jetzt mit den details was
ist das für ein virus das virus ist neu
gehört aber zur bekannten familie der
korona viren und ähnelt dem saas virus
an dem 2002 2003 rund 800 menschen
starben beim sars virus hatten wir doch
in sehr gefährlichen erreger vor uns es
gibt ein paar eigenschaften in diesem
erreger die vermuten lassen dass die
krankheitsentstehung sehr ähnlich laufen
wird so dass ich eigentlich auch damit
rechne dass das eine gefährliche
infektionskrankheit ist inzwischen ist
bekannt dass das neue corona virus in
bestimmten fällen von mensch zu mensch
übertragen werden kann
was sind die symptome eine infektion
zeigt sich mit kopfschmerzen husten und
fieber auch lungenentzündungen sind
möglich eine spezielle therapie gibt es
nicht nur die symptome können behandelt
werden wie gefährdet des deutschland
experten rechnen damit dass hier
einzelne krankheitsfälle auftreten
werden
es gebe aber derzeit keinen grund zur
sorge
auch nicht für reisende nach asien das
risiko einer infektion dort sei bislang
gering
wir müssen eher ein augenmerk haben auf
bürger aus den betroffenen ländern die
bei uns einreisen und die natürlich
nicht in dem moment wo sie am flughafen
aussteigen schon symptome haben sondern
erst dann nach ein paar tagen hier krank
werden das heißt es sind dann die ärzte
hier im land die aufmerksamkeit
aufmerksam sein müssen und die
gesundheitsämter die das ganze verfolgen
müssen
was wir bislang über die neue
lungenkrankheit aus china wissen die
wichtigsten fakten zum corona virus
gibt's zum nachlesen auf heute.de die
verantwortung für den holocaust kennt
keinen schlussstrich das sagt
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
heute in israel
der anlass seiner reise vor 75 jahren
wurde das konzentrationslager auschwitz
befreit
morgen wird steinmeier als erster
bundespräsident in der holocaust
gedenkstätte yad vashem sprechen
steinmeier wurde von israels präsident
rené préval ihn empfangen
danach traf er sich mit überlebenden des
holocaust steinmeier sagte um heute die
verantwortung die nicht endet an weitere
generationen weiterzugeben brauchen wir
das reden über die einzelschicksale nach
washington wo sich republikaner und
demokraten gestern im senat 13 stunden
lang stritten und zwar nur über den
ablauf des amtsenthebungsverfahrens
gegen präsident donald trump jetzt steht
fest sowohl anklage als auch
verteidigung haben für ihre plädoyers 24
stunden zeit verteilt über drei tage
anschließend können die senatoren
schriftlich fragen stellen und erst dann
wird darüber entschieden ob überhaupt
noch zeugen gehört werden
das ist eine niederlage für die
demokraten ines trams aus washington es
war eine zähe marathonsitzung bis in die
frühen morgenstunden der senat wird zum
gerichtssaal hier wird der prozess über
präsident trumps amtsenthebung
stattfinden
die verfahrensregeln dafür bestimmen die
senatoren mit republikanischer mehrheit
zuvor hatten die republikaner alle elf
änderungsanträge der demokrat
abgeschmettert nun wird das verfahren
zunächst ohne zeugen und ohne dokumente
aus ministerien und weißem haus beginnen
ein schneller prozess soll es werden so
wie präsident trump traurig zu sehen
dass senatoren hierfür vertuschung
stimmen gegen zeugen absolut unhaltbar
verräterisch so kann man die beweise
gegen präsident trump nicht ehrlich
abwägen
die linie von chance verteidigern trump
ist unschuldig das
amtsenthebungsverfahren rein politisch
motiviert
die demokraten wollen präsident frank
vom wahlzettel löschen
das sagen sie zwar nicht gerade heraus
aber das ist genau das was sie hier
wollen die stimmung immer wieder
aggressiv der vorsitzende richter greift
ein
bitte bedenken sie dass sie vor der
bedeutendsten beratenden versammlung der
welt sprechen die hat diesen titel weil
ihre mitglieder normalerweise so reden
wie es einem zivilen diskurs entspricht
die spielregeln sind nun also festgelegt
ganz nach dem geschmack des weißen
hauses damit droht das verfahren zur
farce zu verkommen
es wird ein prozess der herkömmlichen
regeln nicht entspricht republikaner ihr
seid feiglinge steht auf dem schild
dieses demonstranten er ist enttäuscht
dass die republikaner keinen anderen
prozess zulassen wollen
das handy des reichsten mannes der welt
von jeff bezos dem chef von amazon ist
offensichtlich gehackt werden
der fall ist ebenso mysteriös wie
kompliziert und beschäftigt jetzt sogar
die uno die geht davon aus dass die
spionage datei direkt vom saudischen
kronprinzen kam und forderte die usa zu
ermittlungen auf jeff bezos ist nämlich
auch eigentümer der zeitung washington
post für die jamaika schoggi gearbeitet
hatte dass es der journalist der in der
saudischen botschaft in istanbul
ermordet wurde
drahtzieher soll prinz mohammed bin
salman gewesen sein weil ihm die
berichterstattung nicht gefallen habe
in new york steht heute der frühere
hollywood produzent harvey weinstein vor
gericht mehr als 80 frauen werfen ihm
sexuelle übergriffe vor der fall 1 team
hat im oktober 2017 die miet debatte
ausgelöst unter diesem hashtag meldeten
sich frauen weltweit zu wort und
berichteten über sexuelle übergriffe von
missbrauch und diskriminierung
millionenfach vor gericht in new york
werden jetzt zwei fälle verhandelt
johannes hano berichtet gebrechlich wird
der einst mächtige medien mogul als er
heute morgen in begleitung seiner
anwälte zum auftakt der verhandlung vor
gericht erscheint er fühle sich als
opfer werde auf unschuldig plädieren
hieß es aus seinem umfeld
alle sexuellen handlungen seien immer
einvernehmlich gewesen
mehr als 80 frauen unter ihnen gründet
parker und angelina jolie beschuldigen
waits den sie sexuell belästigt genötigt
oder vergewaltigt zu haben
manche fälle sind verjährt in anderen
hat sich mainz den außergerichtlich
verglichen
zwei fälle aber werden jetzt in new york
verhandelt wegen vergewaltigung und
sexueller nötigung
auch wenn wo einst ihn in der
öffentlichkeit längst als schuldig gilt
ganz so einfach ist der fall dann doch
nicht erklärt uns die new yorker
strafverteidigerin stacy schneider
die verteidigung ist im besitz von e
mails des opfers anleihen steen die aus
der zeit nach der angeblichen
vergewaltigung stammen die position der
verteidigung wird sein wäre sie
tatsächlich von reinziehen vergewaltigt
worden
warum schreibt sie ihm dann das ihn
vermisst und gerne wieder sehen möchte
größte herausforderung für das gericht
war es vor beginn der verhandlung zwölf
geschworene zu finden die unabhängig von
der öffentlichen meinung eine
entscheidung von großer tragweite
treffen können über freiheit oder
lebenslange haft für den angeklagten
der vorsitzende richter hat die
geschworenen noch einmal eindringlich
aufgefordert alle öffentlichen
diskussionen aus ihren köpfen zu
verbannen und sich nur auf die fakten zu
fokussieren eine herkulesaufgabe
angesichts des öffentlichen interesses
und der gesellschaftlichen bedeutung
dieses falls
mindestens sechs wochen wird hier in new
york jetzt verhandelt ausgang völlig
offen und damit nach deutschland wenn
sie in den letzten jahren ein auto
gemietet haben von der firma buchbinder
einem der größten verlierer in
deutschland dann kann es sein dass ihre
kundendaten ungeschützt zugänglich waren
das melden die zeit und das
computermagazin c t es geht offenbar um
daten von 3 millionen kunden auch
verträge mit namen adressen führerschein
informationen nicht bekannt ist bisher
ob kriminelle die sicherheitslücke
ausgenutzt haben der diesel skandalös
für daimler immer teurer der autobauer
rechnet mit bis zu 1,5 milliarden euro
zusätzlich und gab deshalb jetzt eine
pflichtmitteilung für seine aktionäre
heraus daimler geht davon aus das
laufende gerichtsverfahren und auflagen
von behörden noch einmal ins geld gehen
die zahlen trüben die bilanz für 2009 10
zusätzlich
schon im november hatte daimler ein
sparprogramm angekündigt
was willst du werden welcher job soll es
sein diese frage begleitet jugendliche
in den letzten schuljahren
viele nennen dann berufe die sie aus der
elterngeneration kennen
zu viele sagen experten und stützen sich
dabei auf die jüngste auswertung der
internationalen pisa studie
dabei bietet die digitalisierung ganz
neue berufschancen peter böhme hat sich
bei schülern umgehört
schulbeginn heute morgen matheunterricht
der 9d am gymnasium geroweiher in
mönchengladbach sie sind vierzehn oder
fünfzehn bald kommt das abitur und was
kommt wenn sie 30 sind
ich denke ich werde grund schweren sein
weil ich schon immer interesse hatte an
sozialem ich hatte so den plan
informatik oder wirtschaftsinformatik zu
erklären
momentan tendiere eher zu beschaffen das
ist bis dahin mein medizinstudium
abgeschlossen habe und etwas im bereich
chirurgie machen diese wünsche decken
sich laut oecd studie mit denen der
altersgenossen weltweit erst den
lehrerinnen oder auch anwältin ganz vorn
bei den mädchen ingenieur manager oder
it experte bei den jungen traditionelle
jobs also eher im fokus heute noch mehr
als früher im jahr 2000 wünschten sich
43 prozent der befragten einen besonders
bekannten beruf laut der studie sind es
nun sogar 46 prozent auch in deutschland
viele dieser berufe sind berufe des
neunzehnten und zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
nicht des einundzwanzigsten jahren das
ist gelingt es also unzureichend wurde
die welt die zukunft der arbeit näher an
die jungen menschen heranzubringen
was kann schule nun tun viele
veranstalten bereits jobbörsen bei denen
unternehmen sich und ihre berufe
vorstellen auch in mönchengladbach und
hier gehen sie noch weiter
schüler beratungstag eingeführt vor zwei
jahren wo es auch darum geht dass wir
schon frühzeitig in jedem jahr mit jedem
schüler sprechen um mit ihm zu überlegen
so wird es für dich weitergehen wo
könnte es für dich hin gehen was sind
deine ziele berufsfindung für die
zukunft denn eine reihe etablierter jobs
wird es in der digitalen neuen
arbeitswelt nicht mehr geben so jetzt
traumberuf sportmoderatorin es wird auch
nicht aussterben ist uns zum tennis
melden schon für philipp kohlschreiber
sind die australian open bereits beendet
er musste wegen eines eingerissenen
bauchmuskels sein zweitrundenmatch gegen
den etv weltmeisters der fahne city pass
aus griechenland absagen gut in schwung
ist dagegen julia görges die nach fünf
jahren mal wieder die dritte runde
erreichte erleichterung bei julia görges
nach einem spiel das auch anders hätte
ausgehen können
die deutsche tritt zwar mutig auf
erlaubt sich mit ihrer risikoreichen
spielweise allerdings auch leichter
fehler 43 stehen am ende auf dem zettel
manche situation hätte ich besser
spielen können das weiß ich auch selber
aber grundsätzlich am ende steht ein
sieg das ist das was zehnter denn trotz
verlorenen ersten satzes hält dirks an
ihrem matchplan fest weiter volles
risiko
der zweite satz zu ihren gunsten die
auch der dritte durch das 4 6 6 3 und 7
zu 5 steht bis zum ersten mal seit 2015
wieder in runde drei trifft dort auf die
us amerikanerin alison riske die
deutschen fans open gewinner kevin
krawietz andreas mies sind dagegen im
doppel gleich in runde eins
ausgeschieden in zwei sätzen gegen die
kasachen publik kukuschkin
handball live im zdf gibt es in einer
knappen stunde wieder das letzte em
hauptrundenspiel der deutschen
mannschaft gegen tschechien yorck polus
in wien
da gilt es an die euphorie der letzten
partie anzuknüpfen
küstrin das ist ganz wichtig und vor
allem brauchen in konzentrationen damit
diese erst gar nicht abnimmt hat der
deutsche handballbund das heutige spiel
gegen tschechien als eine art casting
für die qualifikation der olympischen
spiele aus gruppen mit der mannschaft
jedenfalls weil es jeder worauf es
ankommt und jeder spieler betrug
konzentriert heute zur sache geht
20.15 jetzt losgehen da sind wir gerne
dabei vielen dank york zurück nach wien
fußball rekordmeister bayern münchen hat
sich mit alvaro odriozola von real
madrid verstärkt der 24 jährige
rechtsverteidiger und spanische
nationalspieler kommt als leihgabe bis
zum saisonende und würde am liebsten
bereits am samstag gegen schalke
auflaufen
tja kaum da und gleicht das topspiel
christi vielen dank
wenn ein großer und ein kleiner
aufeinandertreffen diese geschichte
haben wir jetzt noch marmor stufen sind
so eine sache einerseits sehr attraktiv
andererseits auch nicht ganz ohne vor
allem vor ganz besonderen publikum
mitten in der generalaudienz des papstes
wer lässt sich nicht irritieren und am
ende gibt es applaus für beide klein und
groß sie lauten 3 16 23 33 41 47 und die
superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 7
so das wetter noch dass sie ziemlich
trübe und trocken aus und weshalb wir
dringend regeln brauchen sagt ihnen
gleich gunter czisch und das war der
mittwoch bei uns morgen sind wir wieder
für sie da und zwar sehr gerne nachher
empfehle ich ihnen aber erst die
kollegin marietta slomka in der handball
halbzeitpause gegen 21 uhr 15
danke fürs zuschauen in allen einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
und dann bliebe zuschauer das ruhige und
trockene wetter hält bei uns an dabei
können wir noch sehr viel regen
vertragen denn die bodenfeuchte ist viel
zu gering
in etwa 1 meter 80 tiefe ist es vor
allen dingen im osten und süden viel zu
trocken dort herrscht eine
außergewöhnliche dürfe nur nach westen
hin ist etwas besser und hier in den
weißen gebieten kann man sagen da reicht
es da reicht die feuchtigkeit aus und
wir brauchen mehr feuchtigkeit im boden
damit die bäume im wald zum beispiel im
nächsten jahr gut wachsen ja es kommt
kein regen dazu heute nacht meist trüb
der himmel mit nebel und hochnebel
klaren himmel an den küsten und hier an
den alpen david sagen wieder am
kältesten minus zehn grad morgen früh
auch im norden um null grad das bedeutet
reifglätte und tagsüber erwarten wir
dann meist wieder ähnlich wie heute 4
bis 7 grad nur nebel bleibt es teilweise
auch bei dauerfrost ja und es wird ein
trüber tag werden im norden zieht zu und
das war in diesem frischen südwesten
dann haben wir einen streifen am
nordrand der mittelgebirge
da können sie mal ein bisschen heller
sein mit sonnenschein und auch im
bayerischen wald schwarzwald und an den
alpen ist es freundlicher aber
zwischendrin haben wir auch den nebel
und hochnebel ja am freitag geht das so
ganz ähnlich weiter samstag und sonntag
es wird vor allem im norden eher trüb
sein
im süden kann auch hier und da mal ein
bisschen die sonne rauskommt
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut